des commerces vacants des logements
vétustes la 2e rue commerciale du
centre-ville de montargis et peu
attractive
durant six ans la ville va bénéficier du
soutien de l'état et de partenaires avec
pour objectif revitaliser son centre
ville mon problème de ces villes
moyennes ce sont des villes qui ont
perdu de la population qui ont perdu
dans un périmètre industriel avec les
conséquences sur le commerce sur l'état
sur l'habitat dans la vie la
détérioration de l'habitat le manque de
personnes vivant dans le centre-ville et
la désertification des centres league et
donc de l'attractivité 220 communes vont
se partager une enveloppe de 5 milliards
ce sont les maires qui décident des
projets prioritaires à montargis ils
sont liés au commerce et à l'urbanisme
comme la réhabilitation de cette place
voyez qu'on est dans une place très très
automobile et on pourrait avoir beaucoup
plus de place pour les piétons regarder
largeur des voies ça représente c'est
pas utile
1 on peut faire circuler les voitures
dans des espaces plus contraints elles
seront moins vite et puis surtout on
aura plus de place pour les piétons les
terrasses de cafés de restaurants et les
commerces qui voudront s'étendent et
puis le parking aussi au printemps 2010
9 la halle giraudet sera vitré pour y
créer cinq commerces alimentaires
ambulants d'autres projets à l'échelle
de l'agglomération participeront à doper
l'attractivité du territoire
l'aménagement d'un port de plaisance
coût 10 millions d'euros pour trois ans
de chantier et peut-être l'acquisition
de la caserne gudin à l'abandon depuis
près de dix ans les négociations de
cession avec l'état propriétaire n'ont
toujours pas abouti
on a bon espoir dans les prochains mois
disons de pouvoir céder l'état pourra
céder ce site à la collectivité qui
ensuite on disposera pour faire ses
projets avant tout projet patience les
bâtiments caché par cette forêt devront
être démolies et le site dépollué